you almost have a show right before the
office that didn't go through yes that's
good good memory yeah I was supposed to
be on this TV show and on the way to the
table read for it I ran into this TV
executive and he's like oh I'm so
excited we're gonna do the American
version of the office and I had seen the
English version I loved it and I was
like outside I was like oh that's great
inside I was like [__] I want to be on
that like okay you got to go to the
table read and the read through went so
bad they pulled the plug on the spot by
the time I got home they were like
they're not shooting they closed the
donuts up even huh and I was like inside
I was like I get to audition for the
office sure enough month later
auditioned for the office and got Dwight
a few months after that